hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's ein vegetarisches
hauptgericht ich werde keine loni mit
spinat und käse füllen und es haben sich
schon mehrere zuschauer keine loni
gewünscht und ich hoffe dass ich mit
dieser variante euren geschmack
natürlich treffe ich habe jetzt schon
mehrmals zubereitet bei mir kommt da
noch so eine tomatensoße drüber und dann
ist das rezept für mich wirklich sehr
perfekt ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal die
zutaten für die füllung und später dann
für die tomatensoße für die füllung
traurig 500 gramm spinat 320 gäste da
nämlich dem gase weichkäse ein eine
prise chili eine knoblauchzehe etwas
muskat und pfeffer und hier habe ich
noch 20 cannelloni den spieler habe ich
es bereits gewaschen und hierfür eine
überschwemmung gefahr
macht nichts da kommt schon eine hand
und ein handtuch und jetzt nehme ich den
spinat und werde ihn einfach bisschen
klein schneiden und dann in einem topf
dünnsten damit er zusammenfällt
jetzt am anfang nach sehr viel aus aber
gleich wieder zusammenfällt ist ja gar
nicht so jetzt habe ich hier schon mal
den topf erhitzt und kann ich den
spielern geben
ganz ohne fett da geht es nicht wirklich
nur darum dass er an volumen verliert
und einfach zusammenfällt
die knoblauchzehe hake ich jetzt auch in
feine scheiben und die gebe ich dann
auch mit dazu und werde dann eben den
spinat ein bisschen durchführen und
jetzt gleich auch den deckel drauf geben
damit er eben schön zusammenfällt
der spinat ist jetzt schon ziemlich
eingefallen
also man sieht auch hier ist es wirklich
noch ganz wenig im topf zurückgeblieben
da das ist einfach noch schneller die
feuchtigkeit verdunsten und schaltet den
herd aus damit einfach abkühlen kann
und ich kann nicht in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die tomatensoße zubereiten und
habe hier die vorab hier vorne wie
zutaten gerichtet ich brauche für die
tomatensoße einen esslöffel olivenöl ein
bis zwei schalotten 2 esslöffel
tomatenmark einen würfel zucker jeweils
einen halben teelöffel salz und oregano
eine dose tomaten stücke eventuell 200
milliliter wasser und käse zum
überbacken und zwar nehme ich da den
gasquet soll es still jetzt mal zur
seite und kann schon mal den topf
erhitzen und das olivenöl reingeben und
die schalotten jetzt fein in würfel
schneiden
die schalotten werden jetzt im olivenöl
angebraten und zwar so lange bis sie
glasig sind bei mit dem hoher hitze sei
etwa ein bis zwei minuten
da kommen jetzt die restlichen zutaten
mit rein also tomatenmark die gewürze
der zucker und auch die tomaten aus der
kasse
wieso sind sie etwa zehn minuten
einkochen bisher spinat auch abgekühlt
und falls hier die flüssigkeit zu
schnell verdunstet könnt ihr eben nach
bedarf auch vom wasser zufügen
der spinat sitz abgekühlt und jetzt muss
ich die füllung pürieren
deswegen gebe ich das hier ein hohes
gefäß vorher so ein bisschen ausdrücken
falls noch zu viel flüssigkeit
flüssigkeit drin ist
da kommen jetzt die restlichen zutaten
mit rein also schon ein bisschen pfeffer
salz brauche ich jetzt kein so weil ich
ja gleich den gar sie weiss käser nehme
und der ist ja schon leicht salzig und
ich hab jetzt den infekt stufe 60 dann
gibt es natürlich auch in mit weniger
fett je mehr fett drin ist und so creme
geist natürlich auch und uns schmeckt
zum beispiel morgens beim frühstück
immer ganz gut und vor allem aufs brot
mit bisschen tomaten und oliven ist er
wirklich sehr lecker dann noch das 1
jetzt kommt da noch ein bisschen
muskatnuss wird rein nur eine kleine
prise und ich kann die füllung jetzt
pürieren
am einfachsten lassen sich die kanone
jetzt mit einer spritze für deswegen
habe ich hier vorne jetzt eine lok hülle
in einem einblick spritzbeutel und
wetter ist die masse hinein
und jetzt einfach die füllung zu
spritzen
jetzt denke ich sie keine loni mit der
tomatensauce
zum überbacken nehme ich jetzt den gaza
krise und zwar deswegen weil er einfach
so schöne schmelz eigenschaften hat ich
nehme den morgens auch gerne in toast
mit bisschen tomaten zum beispiel oder
mir jetzt rinder schinken mit passt
immer da schmeckte richtig gut und
deswegen passt ja auch hier ganz gut auf
die cannelloni da kommt jetzt ein
bisschen was oben drauf und den ofen
habe ich jetzt auch schon bereits
vorgeheizt auf 200 grad ober unterhitze
und jetzt werden die kanäle 30 minuten
im backofen bei 200 grad gebacken
also die cannelloni sie jetzt fertig so
ihr zu dem krieg schon das auf deinen
teller und ihr fehlt eine kleine ecke
denn die habe ich schon gegessen also
typisch italienische kolonie oder justiz
geführt
das ist doch ein bisserl getürkt müsse
getötet
ich habe stadtrekord da habe ich
wahrgenommen und stadt kasan habe ich
kasse genommen weil hätte er weiß geht
er macht das eben so schön cremig und
würzig das heißt man muss es gar nicht
weiter würzen und ich mag den cut ganz
gerne ganz frisch aus dem ofen weil er
sonst so schön lang
seht aber dass der aufsteiger die
katalonische standen jetzt etwa zehn
minuten damit du dich nicht verbrennen
richtig genial wirklich also ich bin der
meinung man kann nicht behaupten dass
man jemals gelebt hat wenn man nach
diese kanäle
obwohl 40
ich finde die füllung ist sehr cremig
damit dass ich den spinat mit dem käse
püriert habe hat mir wirklich eine ganz
kluge füllung da drinnen rechts leckeres
vegetarisches rezept also ich bin ja
kein ich mir kein vegetarier diesmal ja
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen das ding ist
echt gigantisch
er muss jetzt freut wahnsinn also die
gast bei mir auch wirklich schon öfter
und die kann man ja wirklich immer
abwandeln und variieren wie man möchte
ebenfalls ein sehr schnelles und sehr
einfaches mittagessen und ich hoffe dass
ich eure hunger auch gewählt haben oder
zeigen die kamera hier erzeugt man hier
so lecker geschmack erinnert sie anlass
an ihr eigentlicher zu wert kann der
cannelloni hat könnt ihr im prinzip auch
diese passte dieser spinat führung auf
lasagne blätter streichen aber ich finde
den cannelloni irgendwie schöner zum
portionieren und schließe auch wirklich
sehr einfach gemacht sind die fotos
schon gemacht
also kann es zu engpässen du kannst
alles zu ändern
menschenrechte stoff wirklich weiter
heisst also viel spaß beim nachkochen
und wir sehen uns das nächste mal
westantarktis unbedingt nach umwege
auch für kinder